i'm so happy that i get to talk about it
now like first and foremost i am a fan
so when amy pascal and kevin feige and
and john watts asked i love this guy
talk to me about i'm not mad at him at
all i'm so like also so proud of him for
trying to hide it from us right working
so hard and he's had such a big year of
press he has to go in front of
journalists all year right
i have so much respect for him we
spoiled it for ourselves so he was
trying to help us
i feel about it and then the fact that i
get to be one of those people wearing
the suit next to my actual spider-man
hero toby maguire and the brilliant
incredibly talented heartfelt fighter
you know what if you talk trash about
one of them like my favorite spider-man
and then another one i don't like that
much
toby babar if i hear that tom the kid
younger brother i snuck into a theater
it is sweet that he calls him like he's
the middle child of the two brothers
that's totally the energy plays
now are you coming back
will you come back that's the question
andrew garfield's experience
amazing spider-man 3 got to happen if
there's a way
for me to continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels of
service to an audience of service to a
theme because gotta have purpose man you
can't just like bring it back for no
reason i'm open of course i'm very very
sounds like a yes
right
of course that would be special every
time spiderman will be special sony
would make so he's coming back
just come back andrew just come back we
miss you it's your time welcome back to
new rockstar spiderman no way home
pulled off several miraculous feats and
at the top of that list was making us
all appreciate how truly great andrew
garfield was as peter parker and how
deserving this guy is of his own third
film andrew garfield is now saying he is
open and our legs are open for this guy
to make a landing right in the middle
because we are now hearing some totally
unconfirmed rumors but rumors
nonetheless that sony might be actually
looking into this
and if we could will toby mcguire and
andrew garfield into existence once more
hey we can do it again can't wait come
on
this is inside marvel it's our weekly
marvel reaction show i'm eric boss and
i'm back this week with mtmt welcome
back from your break
buddy back at it again at krispy kreme
what's going on gang i missed you guys
so much vacation was not vacation
without you guys so right now i feel
like i'm involved in vacation uh with
you talking nerds well new rock stars
those are new rock stars without you
empty but hey i gotta i gotta hand you
some props here good on you for
scheduling your vacation right up past
when philip was doing performance
reviews yesterday
man 2021 was a hard
hard year of theories to come to terms
with i gotta say uh but next year next
year we're coming for you empty you're
gonna have to be in the hot seat right
there with me we're gonna we're gonna
merge our trials together it's gonna be
a few good men both of us delivered the
code red from mephisto mephisto may have
ordered the code red but you and i are
those two marines who who carried it out
so let's do it hey i'm ready
i'm ready for molina judgment
no you're not no you're not
nobody is
well in this episode of inside marvel
we're going to talk about this new
andrew garfield spider-man film rumors
that are out there what would that film
look like if it were to happen and what
would really need to change from the
2012 and 2014 films and really how would
this affect the live-action spider-verse
with the tom holland peter parker and
sony's plans for miles morales because
you know they're going to get around to
him eventually so we're going to talk
about all this stuff also some other
spider-man related mcu questions moving
forward throughout this calendar year
but before we get to that we still have
some amazing designs inspired by the
huge year in marvel that we just had all
available at new rockstarsmerch.com
these include our awesome strange
entanglement design our hawkeye inspired
kingpin shirt and trust a bro moving
company shirt so be sure to get all
these at
newrockstarsmerch.com all right mt let's
dive right into it all right buddy our
first question of the day is is andrew
garfield coming back to play peter
parker for another film because that is
the big question that we have all had
and wanted ever since no way home
because this man is incredible he is
he's literally peter parker he's my
favorite he's one of my favorites
and you know what mt um when this has
been coming up it reminded me of like
there was an old episode of rogue theory
that you were on i think before you
joined the rockstars full-time where we
were talking about different like
spider-verse tie-ins and your um opinion
was that like the mark webb films didn't
get their proper dude mark webb the
director of course of uh the amazing
spider-man movies um i think that those
movies are underrated like i know that
like i'm not supposed to say that i i
enjoyed amazing spider-man 2 and
everybody's like oh my god it's the
worst spider-man movie though that may
be true
like the actual stuff in those movies
were fantastic that was one thing i
learned about i don't really like that
really appreciates andrew garfield i
really like that time people were giving
credit mark webb cinematography
especially in the amazing spider-man 2
magnificent magnificent so good so like
i would love for him to come back for a
third one yes for sure so there's a lot
of great things from those 2012 and 2014
films that are worth re-exploring i i
think people are now discovering that
those movies in the same way spider-man
3 from toby maguire was not a complete
trash there's a lot of amazing stuff
that uh almost warranted another
follow-up film uh there was going to be
a fourth tobey maguire spider-man movie
there was gonna be a third andrew
garfield's writer movie it's just like
right sony as a studio would get a
little nervous when the numbers weren't
what they thought so we gotta reboot it
but hey you know uh to their credit
rebooting it so many times has only paid
off in dividends now to have so many
different
we've always meant to do it but i think
of all of these andrew garfield's having
a huge moment especially right now like
out of everyone in this massive cast of
no way home i feel like he's the cast
member everyone is buzzing about and
last night he just won the golden globe
for best actor in a musical or comedy
boom which he's so good at tick tick
boom uh the guy is such a good actor and
this isn't anything against tom
hollander toby mcguire tom holland is
incredible the energy he's brought to
peter parker has been in many fans eyes
perfect like what we've been wanting for
he has this like youthful uh panic
almost like
almost like what michael j fox brought
to marty mcfly and oh 100 just in the
sense of panic but the physical
commitment he brings to that like tom
holland is
doing a lot of fun stunt work a lot of
tripping around the room like he's just
a delight to watch the character feels
like a real goofy kid that would exist
in real life that's why we love him
and and then toby uh has brought so much
of the role he was our first live-action
spider-man for my generation for sure
this is the spider-man that i compare
every other spider-man 2. and the the
politeness that he plays the k he just
has this wholesome sweetness to him that
you know when you watch spider-man 3 and
he does the whole dark turn like it is
campy but it's you get to see that other
side of toby mcguire's portrayal of the
character that just makes you appreciate
everything else he has done to build up
that character and build up that trust
with him and that's not an easy thing to
do i think toby dugar nailed the whole
turning evil thing in spider-man 3
because what would happen if this nerd
was like i'm gonna try to be cool he
would fail this is what this nerd thinks
is cool it's not what's happening is
cool it's what a nerd thinks would be
exactly
jump on tables i
agree i think it's perfect um but andrew
garfield brings a dimension to the
reason he's cast for this version of
peter parker is i mean they knew going
into these movies that they're going to
kill off twin stacy and they needed uh
peter parker who could really really
sell
the grief
um garfield is he knows how to act he
knows how to do emotion like that is
constantly crying
and like i really love that andrew
garfield is super emotional in his
movies because like we don't see a lot
of emotion from like a lot of male
character like a lot of male heroes i
feel so like seeing andrew garfield get
emotional in those movies i'm like yeah
i like this crying spider-man more
crying spider-man please
there's there's a wholesome aspect to it
and i'll say that like in fairness of
all the other actors who have been in
these movies uh the scripts usually
don't require that from them you know
they usually are more comedic they're
more light-hearted uh when characters
die they uh they are not cut to like we
did have a moment where tom holland had
to react to tony stark dying but think
of all the actors who they had in that
battle and they only cut to like a few
different people when tony stark died
you know and all these people are
capable of showing grief in different
ways but it's just the nature of these
scripts when when deaths happen they
don't linger too much on the death they
cut to the funeral but i mean we've even
had major characters die and we didn't
get funerals in those movies you know so
uh that's just been the nature of the
mcu instead what we'll do is they'll
create entire disney plus series that
just deal with characters grief and uh
that's actually worked out pretty well i
gotta say you know between one division
between hawkeye you know these shows
have been successful but when it comes
to andrew garfield in interviews this
past week andrew has said as we saw at
the top of this episode he's totally
down to return as peter parker in a
future film just the conditions have to
be right the story has to be right uh he
also told variety recently that his
peter is a working-class boy from queens
that knows struggle and loss and is
deeply empathetic i would try to borrow
peter parker's ethical framework in that
if there was an opportunity to step back
in and tell more of that story i would
have to feel very sure and certain in
myself and yeah it sounds like he's
coding some signals to the studio like
if you want to tell a certain kind of
story i can be your guy uh and he did
the homework in spiderman no way home he
proved
to anyone who had any doubt in his
ability as an actor and his ability to
capture an audience in the suit he
proved this is why i was initially cast
with this role i can pull this off he
when he's that moment that you mentioned
when he saved mj he breaks down in tears
clearly remembering gwen uh he said
earlier in the film that he hadn't
gotten over gwen's death became rageful
stop pulling his punches i honestly like
he kind of created an arc for himself in
this movie
um and the writers did that as well but
the reason it works is because andrew
garfield sells it so perfectly
um now i want to remind us all where the
2014 andrew garfield film left us uh
because it's important to remember that
sony was clearly setting up a sinister
six conflict in that universe we had
dane duhan as harry osborne we had paul
giamatti as rhino technically recyphens
lizard was still alive at that universe
he had been on the short list of gustav
fears and we also got a glimpse of a doc
ock suit a vulture suit and there was
some talk of craven hunter joining this
lineup as well as possibly mysterio
possibly chameleon it's clear that sony
started working their mysterio and
vulture plans into their mcu films we
also got to remember felicity jones
played harry's assistant felicia in this
film possibly being set up as felicia
hardy black cat now there was some
interesting chatter about what a third
uh version of these movies was going to
be there's some interviews with dennis
leary later on who revealed that one
idea
just one idea for the next andrew
garfield movie was to dig even deeper
into oscorp's history with biomedical
engineering and that peter was going to
acquire a formula that would allow him
to regenerate the people in his life who
had died so that could have included
captain stacy gwen stacy uncle ben
norman osborne peter's parents
uh yeah so it you know when we just hear
that kind of thing in in a headline on
nerd news website we kind of balk at it
especially if it's coming from dennis
leary who's just kind of like all this
stuff is stupid um but i
the idea of having that opportunity to
uh to regenerate people but choosing not
to do it like we've seen that played out
in like horror uh yeah before you know
like they're not the same they're the
same to me right right gwen
uh like
just the idea of that is uh brings us
into a nice horror territory that i like
these andrew garfield movies exploring
how kind of dark and
moody they get i i would love to see
like a clone saga even though the clone
saga in the comics is this huge like
controversial thing a lot of people
don't want to see the clone sage went on
for too long i get it i understand the
jackal and like like you said like
i the the idea of all of these people
that died in peter parker's life has
always messed with his mind and like
he's always wished that he could just go
back in time and like undo the things
that he made a mistake on and like
literally seeing gwen stacy again
like a cloned version does make sense
because he lost both gwen stacy and
captain stacy so like if a um amazing
spider-man 3 were to happen we would
probably see captain stacy too because
all that grief and that regret and all
that um guilt that he has with um the
them two dying so like i think that the
clone saga is a really interesting way
to go to explore that emotional side of
andrew garfield peter parker for sure
yeah it just i mean if they told dennis
leary about it it means that they were
going to bring back these actors in some
way that was part of the pitch
but we have to remember that from sony's
perspective
you know you have to wonder how much
they've thought about the logic of their
multiverse and how everything's connect
i don't know if they totally have
thought about it as much as some of the
crazy ass fans have on youtube but um no
way the fans always think about it more
than the actual as much as you thought
about something there's a fan out there
who's thought about it more than you
know but the uh from their perspective
the universe that their villain films
are set in might still be that same
andrew garfield continuity because in
their eyes it's kind of simpler right
you have the mcu universe and they know
as much to know that's separate but i
think for everything that isn't that i
think they might just feel like there's
a way to connect or they might already
just be connected because they're not
trying to be too interconnected a lot of
these movies but like they're literally
located in different parts of the
country uh and they never really leave
that neighborhood so i think that that
could be the way they look at it uh we
know that morbius is set in the same
universe as venom or at least of in a
minute he references venom in the
trailer uh the cops in that trailer
reference events in san francisco uh now
the more views trailer is also showing
uh the oscorp tower looking exactly as
it does in the android garfield
continuity same logo same building uh
there's also graffiti labeling
spider-man as a murderer yes different
era version of spider-man but it is art
but they call him a murderer which could
line up with andrew garfield saying that
he stopped pulling his punches and he
could have murdered someone he could
have been too violent of a vigilante now
there are a few sticking points of
course michael keaton is playing vulture
and morbius uh points to some kind of
mcu connection there uh morbius has a
weirdly designed daily bugle that
doesn't really line up with the tabloid
design we saw in venom let there be
carnage but in the andrew garfield
continuity i don't think we ever saw a
daily bugle front page or if we did we
didn't stay on it for too long we really
just saw some billboards in the second
movie uh and then we got some angry
emails from j.j and jameson but we never
met that j jonah jameson in that movie
um but a key detail in that 2014 film
the oscorp files that uh that harry
osborne is going through on the
touchscreen reference a whole bunch of
other spider-verse villains including dr
morbius in the lower right corner so
this could just be another clue that
from sony's eyes all spider-man movies
that aren't the mcu tom holland's shared
universe with disney are instead their
own universe where andrew garfield is
still spider-man and could still come
back
and if characters in these villain
movies reference spider-man the
spider-man they're referencing is andrew
garfield why not why not just make that
the case right we don't need to cast a
fourth spider-man unless i would say
you're gonna make miles morales that guy
but why not also just make him your guy
i kind of want miles miles to be in the
mcu instead can we just let
just play with him
i know i know he's yours i know i know
he was just you know
sounds like we could just use the let's
hang out with everybody in the mcu
that'd be a bit fun for us i mean it's
already there
donald glover told us
so let's talk about what an andrew
garfield spider-man movie should look
like uh what and i think the question is
what are the mcu spider-man movies been
missing
because they have been great but there
have been some choices they have made
that have had to close the door on other
parts of peter parker's
character his world so let's let's run
through some options for me i'm just
gonna run down a quick list uh things
like ozcorp because we know there's no
oscorp in the mcu you can explore more
intrigue with oscorp i would say maybe
the andrew garfield films the first two
explored that a bit too much made them
too much about like a political yeah
they kind of delved into the national
treasure a little bit but odds works an
interesting company uh the whole spider
verse of characters mcu can only bring
in certain characters that they get
deals with with sony um things like
horror the mcu is exploring horror in
titles like wanda vision uh
house of harkness um moon knight a
multiverse madness of course but when it
comes to spider-man they like to keep
him in a brighter world where yes his
friends and family die but uh we don't
really
it's hard to imagine right now tom hall
and peter parker reacting to a vampire
or reacting to a zombie unless we saw
and what if he was reacting to zombies
but that wasn't animated the tom holland
live action one right now they haven't
really played with that yet whereas
andrew garfield the way he plays being
grossed out at stuff like just staring
at tony's wrist
it was so perfect my favorite part of
the movie he was just like oh my god i
mean just his reaction to that scene
like the the fifth or sixth time you
watch this movie just watch it for
andrew garfield's reaction
um
and another big thing that the tom
holland movies have not explored at
least not yet is uh peter parker as a
photojournalist for the daily bugle um
that is something that they could
explore more if they have another
trilogy of him as a college student but
i would still imagine just the way
they've made this peter parker is he is
more of an engineer he went to a science
and engineering high school i he hasn't
shown i don't think he's taking a single
photo you know like he didn't have some
he might have taken some selfies and
stuff but like the the only photo uh
gags we've seen is when mr harrington
dropped his
camera in the water at venice you know
like
and that's fine i haven't missed it that
much with this version of peter parker
but that is like a dimension to his
character's relationship with j jonah
jameson that i feel like in spider-man
no way home i would have loved it if
they could have gotten jk simmons out of
a green screen studio and talk to at
least one of these characters because
that is such a funny relationship
between these two this abusive boss and
then a photojournalist who still is so
skilled that the boss has to
begrudgingly work with this guy um
yeah i think that could be something
that we explore more with andrew
garfield's version the characters you
know uh when you see photojournalists
working for the times or the post in
real life
they often are not children they're
they're kind of like grizzled guys
without families who just go anywhere
and they're badasses they go all over
the world they go into war zones like i
kind of want to see that version i want
to see the ad for those like looking for
grizzled man without family to take
picture in warsaw
[Laughter]
maybe that's too extreme for peter
parker sure but i think andrew garfield
could explore that i think we also would
love to see tom holland explore that i
don't think there's anything stopping
that from happening but these are just
some things that as of now have not
really shown up in the mcu so really i
think the question i want to know empty
is if peter parker is played by andrew
garfield in a third movie following his
continuity after no way home what kind
of story do you want to see from him
what what journey do you want to see him
go through well we have heard rumors of
emma stone potentially coming back as
gwen and more specifically spider gwen
who i love and is the character that got
me into comics i love that character so
much so i would love for an amazing
spider-man 3 scenario to just take place
in spider-gwen's world i think that that
very much is in line with you know the
story that is being told with gwen and
captain stacy and the guilt that he
feels i would love if andrew garfield
were just
was 100 percent pushed into the
spider-gwen's world and be like oh my
god there's gwen i need to save her even
though she doesn't need to be saved and
there's captain stacy i killed your
daughter another in another universe i
feel very um depressed and confused but
yeah i think that that's like a natural
continuation of his story because gwen
is in the stations are at the center of
it and they really do want to build this
whole spider verse of characters it
seems so it just makes sense for amazing
spider-man 3 to sort of be a spider-gwen
jump off film i don't know what do you
think yeah i think that's an uh a great
idea mt and
the implication of that is that it would
have to be a multiverse inspired
incident right so for first off to gwen
stacy for her to be alive again uh and
for her to be spider gwen she would have
to come from a reality where she is the
the spider hero so i think but it's
already set up like we already had this
big collision event like it's not that
hard just to say but she's here she's
back yeah i think that honestly that
that morbius universe is this huge
amalgamation universe of like both the
tobey maguire and the mark webb
universes together because like it just
doesn't all of those mobius morbius
questions that we have and they just
don't make sense if it's not this one
big universe because we do see that if
it's not some kind of weird yeah
mishmash that happened after no way home
post the spell i don't think that that's
out of the question i feel like yeah i
think you're right it's just like i
don't know if they already planned on
andrew garfield showing up in morbius
yes they have more time because they
they pushed it back i don't know if
they're gonna reshoot i just think sony
dropped the money do it but would andrew
garfield agree to do that i don't i
don't know he's gonna be like an oscar
front runner now oh yeah he's gonna be
making more money now but he won that
award
i don't want to spend the next couple
weeks worrying about how this will look
anyway i hope he does i think it'll like
even as like a post-credit thing you
know set up his other movie i think when
stacy is perfect uh a spider-gwen where
both of them are spider things and
they're figuring out that relationship i
i think that is one thing that like sony
tried to do early on is they try to
build on andrew garfield and emma
stone's natural chemistry which when you
re-watch those movies they totally do
they work together on screen
um
but like as when you re-watch it knowing
that this is kind of doomed it's kind of
like
like it's hard not to re-watch those
movies and just feel like they're
they're straight up fridging gwen stacy
like the death of gwen stacy story line
of the comics is considered the sacred
thing like gwen stacy has to die it's
like no she didn't have to die it's just
marvel comics in the 80s said oh we need
to have a twist that gets makes it real
dark like you can kill off other people
in peter's life that makes them feel
grief that's what happened with uncle
ben yeah i just think gwen stacy is such
a great character you can her she's so
much more valuable to universe universal
storytelling alive than she is just to
force the character to go through grief
okay emma stone's characterization of
that character was so good like this was
a highly intelligent woman that was more
than capable of helping andrew garfield
as spider-man like this was the perfect
girlfriend for this version of peter
parker so like for for them to just be
like all right we have to follow the
comics continuity and kill her like you
didn't have to like you gotta kill like
you said you could get someone else that
he loved like it's plenty of people for
for peter parker but you gotta also look
at from their their perspective this is
really a debate with like the comics in
the 80s right like because if they were
to bring in gwen stacy in the movies the
number one question every fan would ask
are you gonna kill her are you gonna
kill me
she's most known for from the comics uh
at least at that point now uh with this
arcus spider gwen people have these
other perspective but like i think let
her be the spider gwen gwen stacy not
the oh yeah dead girlfriend oh yeah i
think that needs to she needs to stay
dead that version needs to stay that 100
but uh i i honestly felt the same way
about aunt may and no way home i think
ant-may's death was really really well
executed but just stepping back from
that execution from the concept like
if you were trying to get uh peter
parker to go through grief why not kill
off happy hogan instead like happy hogan
has been this paternal role to peter
honestly it's had more of a relationship
with peter at least coming out of far
from home like you're gonna get that
same reaction out of peter parker but
aunt may they they suddenly adjusted her
character because they wanted to give
mercy to him to me more to do in no way
home to justify killing her off uh but
like i think there's so much more that
can be gotten from her character having
an ongoing relationship with peter
parker in the future then happy hogan
who's really just a vestige of peter
parker's relationship with the avengers
and with tony stark and i think in order
to properly move on from that phase of
his life i thought it would have been a
great opportunity to kill off happy
hogan now that's me talking from like a
storytelling perspective from like a
universe building perspective uh john
favreau showing up as happy hogan in
these different properties it's a
delight and i don't want to lose him
either
you know there's all kinds of fun stuff
that you can do with him i would have
loved if instead of like you know karen
and all the other suit ladies we've
gotten if it was on may talking to peter
in the suit the entire like
a big part of me too
that's [ __ ] creepy
that's terrifying my dead aunt is the
voice that's talking oh no no like
far from home
if she was the suit lady because she
knew after homecoming so like it'd be
great if she was just like all right i'm
helping my nephew let's go do adventures
together um once you give terrible
advice like 100 i think that's a drone
you're approaching i don't really know
though it would be the worst over to the
airport and fly home it would it's like
having your own backseat drive it would
be so funny
i would love it it'd be hilarious i'll
give you that we've kind of gotten on a
tangent here i think ultimately what we
want to see from andrew garfield is uh
is realize what was good about those
2014 films i think he did have like a
really nice chemistry with emma stone he
played it with this wholesomeness
especially i think the way he played the
second of his movies was more of a true
peter parker energy uh he had a
relationship with the city of new york
that
we've really seen tom holland have he's
had a relationship with queens in del
mar's deli with his high school but we
haven't really seen him as like you know
going around manhattan and and getting
to know people who live there and say
hey he did a flip that one time he did
one flip
he did one flip that's right and a lady
gave him a churro
yeah it sounds like i'm faulty in the
tom holland universe i loved all that i
loved exploring queens with peter burger
we hadn't really seen that before so uh
i just think if we were to explore
something with andrew garfield i'm not
saying we should ever end tom holland's
character i still want to see these
movies but i think the the conclusion we
can all draw from no way home is we can
have multiple live-action spider-mans at
the same time and sony shouldn't be
worried about this that people are gonna
like pick and choose which one they're
gonna they're gonna show up for both
we're gonna watch every movie that
andrew garfield is playing spider-man
and we're gonna watch every movie that
tom holland's playing spider-man and
you're gonna like be able to double dip
on the well of your characters you can
have a miles move you can have a gwen
movie you can have a toby maguire go
balls to the wall sony every spider
spider ham i want to see spider ham live
action let's do it
you can do it all and then rake in all
the profit from it fans aren't choosing
one over the other we're going to show
up for both so give us love them all any
spider-man content try to do it do it
put into our eyeballs please we're going
to keep talking about this uh but first
we want to thank helix for sponsoring
this episode disney plus and hbo max
don't do us a lot of favors here at new
rock stars when they release content at
midnight we need sleep guys
but at least we're not losing any sleep
because of a bad mattress helix sleep
has a quiz that matches your body type
and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i got a helix mattress i
love it the quiz matched me with a
medium fur matches the lumbar support
that sleeps cool the mattress ships
right to your door for free no need to
go to a mattress store just go to
helixleve.com inside marvel take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will love it helix
is offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
inside marvel we also want to thank
upstart for sponsoring this episode have
you tried looking at your credit card
statements you are not alone the weight
of debt can be crippling but upstart can
help give you your path to financial
freedom upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment credit history to find you a
smarter rate for your loan you can check
your rate without impacting your credit
score in minutes for loans between 1 000
and 50 000 you can receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com inside marvel that's
upstart.com insidemarvel don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you load them out to be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application and finally we want to thank
sun basket for sponsoring this episode
our friends at sunbasket deliver healthy
meals so you aren't on the hook to shop
and cook for healthy food sunbasket
delivers the joy of eating with bold
flavors organic produce and sustainable
seafood in meats their award-winning
chefs are constantly innovating with new
recipes to keep it interesting each week
sun baskets fresh and easy meals are
perfect for lunch heat and eat in
minutes and you can put dinner on
autopilot with easy to prep meal kits
that impress whoever you're feeding plus
they've got healthy snacks or
grab-and-go breakfast items for busy
mornings whether you eat vegetarian
paleo gluten free or low carb sun basket
has something to check any and every box
you can choose from delicious recipes
like pan seared salmon tikka masala or
honey balsamic glazed chicken with
cabbage apple salad set up weekly
delivery and skip a week when you need
to it's simple and easy and you will
love it right now sunbasket is offering
90 off and a free gift when you order go
to sunbasket.com marvel and into the
promo code marvel at check out that
sunbasket.com
marvel into promo code marvel all right
mt what's our next question
all right buddy um assuming a secret
wars event happens which i you know we
all very much suspect how involved
should it be with this whole
spider-verse scenario that's going on in
the mcu interesting question yeah i
think a fifth avengers movie
could be and really should be secret
wars i think that's the only event
that's big bigger than end game right
now uh unless you were to have some
other kind of crossover event with the
x-men with the fantastic four you could
create a new crisis that isn't uh
grounded in the comics but i think
secret wars is such a cool opportunity
the the 2015 crossover incursion one
that already kind of merged uh the 1610
with the 616 universe in such a cool way
you had dr doom as the villain um now
when it comes to the spider-verse i i
think
i would love to see multiple spider uh
things in it but
the the crossover event i want secret
wars to be is also gonna have like x-men
in it you know and i and i don't want
those spider-men to be diluted in any
way so i think they should just pick one
or two
uh spider-man
uh variants i think you could have your
tom holland one there and then you have
your miles morales there or your gwen
stacy i don't know if i need andrew
garfield until mcguire to be in secret
wars unless they are
the only uh spider-man that's in that
but then i would feel bummed that tom
holland isn't in there because he has a
relationship with all the mcu characters
how do you feel am i am i being
like really measured and i think that
you're being like like in a practical
sense like it makes sense for just like
let's just limit our spider-man because
like then you have all these actors and
you have to like organize schedules like
because i because with the the russo
brothers with the uh avengers projects
especially infinity war and endgame it
was a nightmare for them like organizing
all these people's schedules and like
you know andrew garfield's high in
demand now like it's just less people
the better however i think that if we
can do it if we can't get all these
actors i think that the secret wars
event should be like a huge celebration
of all things live-action marvel so like
let's get everybody as much people let's
get even howard the duck in the howard
the duck movie that we don't even like
from back in the day bring that howard
in every single live action that should
be a huge celebration of like everything
that's ever ever happened um in this one
event and then just end it like just one
huge thing so i think that we should go
all spider-man toby mcguire andrew
garfield as much elements as we can
shove into that movie because it's
secret wars and we'll we'll never have
it again it's like one and done and like
we'll never probably have another secret
award it looks like it has to be one and
done i think that that can be like a
recurring thing like secret wars could
be its own trilogy of secret wars part
one secret word i would absolutely love
if there was this whole secret wars arc
like we just had like the secret wars
saga
oh my god
it's like different dimensions where
these uh folks are being transported to
you just have different people who get
controls of the wheel or that like dr
doom is having a secret war in one
dimension but another uh collage of
characters in another reality a
different battle world landscape look if
pen m can host
74
i am sorry i'm not even gonna finish the
sentence
but you get the idea
no 100 you're 100 right it's true
well moving ahead to uh other marvel
questions it's just a question i have
for you mt dr strange's multiverse of
madness we're getting rumors of all kind
of crazy cameos gonna happen in this
movie i want to ask you which is more
likely patrick stewart as charles xavier
professor x or
toby maguire as spider-man reuniting
with sam raimi director
you know what i think it's it's
definitely got to be patrick stewart
because we just got tobey maguire in no
way home and so like that whole surprise
it was really cool but like i don't
think that'll be like all right here's
here's him again hooray um so it's gotta
be patrick stewart because we haven't
really seen him in a while it it's the
cameo that we all wanted because we
we've all been clamoring for the fox
x-men to join the mcu proper um ever
since the whole ralph bowder thing
didn't 100 pan out the way that we
wanted yet
um so
yeah i think it's patrick stewart for
sure how about you would you yeah i
would say so too um i think having sam
raimi as a director that just feels like
it's a natural fit to bring toby mugari
back in there but i think the issue with
spider-man any time you put spider-man
in a movie it starts to feel a bit like
a spider-man movie now you're going to
say well he's infinity war he was an end
game those weren't spider-man movies but
like we knew that tom holland was
already in that universe and already
kind of a supporting character to the
avengers in that way toby mcguire is
from his own world where he is the front
man and if he's not crossing over into a
spider-man movie he is going to start to
make it feel like a spider-man flavor
and and i don't know if that's exactly
what sam raimi and kevin feige want to
do with multiverse and madness
oh yeah i wouldn't mind seeing him in
the background waving through a portal i
would love that like or or some type of
reference to the raymond universe like
i'll take that any day for sure but that
kind of leads us to our final question
mt why do you think marvel is taking so
damn long with the mutants we've had
them for a while we're now past the
weird uh scheduled delay things of uh
you know of their first year of content
yeah they're already reshooting things
to to make you know doctor strange make
more sense is it just that they didn't
want to introduce mutants and chiang chi
in eternals and in those that first year
of movies and we're going to see them
multiverse madness if they don't show
the multiverse of madness are we right
to start really questioning like what's
the hold up i think that people are very
much justified with being like all right
where are the mutants like it's been
long enough like because it's we all
want it i i get it but like i think that
mutants are going to be introduced
specifically in guardians of the galaxy
three because like we there was this
whole thing of like of people saying
guardians of the galaxy it's going to
usher in this huge new era of the marvel
cinematic universe a couple years ago
and i think that with rumors of the high
evolutionary coming into play in the
guardians 3
i think that he's going to kick off
mutants because he's all about evolution
it's all about like genetic uh stuff and
all that stuff yeah we're gonna with
rocket story we're gonna learn how
rocket was evolved from a lower life
form and he's probably gonna do
something crazy maybe they'll adapt the
evolutionary war uh saga in in from the
comics but yeah i think that it's going
to be herbert windham the high
evolutionary that's gonna like trigger
the um mutants in the entire universe
but what do you think well see i think
uh high evolutionary could give us some
answers on what mutants look like off
worlds off earth you know like in the in
the wider cosmos for sure i think
there's an opportunity there i just
think for most fans their access point
into the x-men into the mutants are the
ones who exist on earth so if you were
to have your first introduction of what
mutants are in the mcu be this guy who
most fans have never heard of you know
who's on another planet i think you and
i would be like cool that makes sense
but i i would imagine kevin feige wants
to introduce
whatever the history of the mutants are
on earth whether that's through magneto
or through wolverine or through
apocalypse i don't think they're going
to use the term x-men i would imagine i
would imagine they're just going to have
mutants and then we're going to see what
different groups they form therefore
so i'm not discounting your theory i
think i think uh guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 could be a place we we learn more
about mutes i just think like you have
opportunities between now and then to do
it maybe i'm just feeling this
unnecessary anxiety that the window is
going to close on on superheroes uh when
it comes to like i think you know right
now a lot of film historians are
comparing the latest marvel craze i mean
it is the biggest genre the biggest
title in hollywood right now it's the
one thing that people are going to
movies for consistently the way westerns
were in the late 60s like they made so
many freaking westerns and they they
made so much money and now like they
really just dropped in popularity thanks
in part to filmmakers like scorsese
george lucas steven spielberg people who
loved and respected westerns but they
made things like sci-fi and crime movies
and and more fast-paced movies uh more
of the standard more the norm uh so i
don't know what would happen i think it
would take
another
uh wave another generation of directors
who make popcorn films that are
more exciting to general audiences than
the marvel movies like they would have
to be ousted from the throne in order
for that to happen i don't think people
just stop caring about something unless
they have something more interesting to
move on to
so um but but i am worried like i think
i think enough time has passed like i
know dark phoenix was only in 2019 which
is only like three years ago
but no one saw that movie
the last extra movies were the deadpool
movies you know and yeah the second one
was 2018. i think we're well beyond the
threshold of how long sony waited to
reboot spider-man as tom holland uh and
i think fans were okay with that i think
marvel has so many great opportunities
and i know they have the money to do it
and i think that they should explore all
opportunities and i think they can uh
they can reassure their investors big
time just by announcing a mutant movie
in the future
it would be really dope i just i just
really want to see jubilee man that's my
favorite i love jubilee let's get it
marvel
lots of lots of great i'd love to see
like a really good scott summers cyclops
nothing against james marsden yes for
once i would just i'm not a fan of
cyclops so like if we could get a good
psychos please marvel let's let's get it
yeah well we'll be talking about this
stuff a lot more in the future but that
is it for this episode of inside marvel
we are still waiting for a trailer for
moon night as soon as uh we learn more
about when moon night's gonna be
happening uh if that drops on disney
plus in the next couple months this show
will shift to being a win today after
show as it's been the case for the other
disney plus shows uh but right now we're
just kind of like looking at what's the
biggest marvel story each week at the
top of the week and mt and are going to
be here reacting to it with you guys
we're talking marvel baby talking marvel
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options in new york source
merch.com follow me at eavos follow mt
at mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast and
we will see you next week thanks for
watching everybody bye love you guys
you